bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live depuis un mois
le volcan combier combrée vieira située
sur l'île de la palma aux îles canaries
est en éruption des milliers d'habitants
ont été évacués et pour certains leurs
habitations ont été totalement détruites
par ses impressionnantes coulées de lave
qu'on observe depuis 30 jours maintenant
vous le voyez sur les images diffusées
en ce moment par l' agence ap peut-être
que julienc une aile en régie voilà nous
peut nous montrer en direct ces images
de ce volcan qui est on le voit bien
actif il continue de projeter de la lawe
descendre le tout dans une énorme
colonne de fumée on va tout comprendre
de l'humeur de ce volcan combrée vieira
avec mon invité bonjour jacques marie
bardintzeff
jacques marie bardintzeff est-ce que
vous m'entendez oui très bien oui voila
merci d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur figaro live vous êtes
volcanologues et professeur à
l'université
paris saclay dans l'essonne alors quand
est ce que le volcan va t-il se calme et
bien on va dire pour l'instant un volcan
en islande l'éruption depuis un mois
comme vous l'avez dit les éruptions
précédent qui en avait une par une ou
deux par siècle elle durer entre trois
semaines et trois mois donc on est dans
la fourchette
jusqu'à maintenant il y avait pas mal de
séisme mes collègues espagnols et
canadiens enregistrés entre 80 et 150 6
me par jour
curieusement depuis ce matin à seulement
10 donc petite pause reprise c'est votre
corps qui décide obhrai un prêt
les images sont impressionnantes de ce
volcan est le sont d'autant plus qu'il
est absolument actifs elles sont aussi
beaucoup plus la nuit quand on voit le
rougeoiement de la lave mais on se
demande aussi aux quais et visuellement
c'est impressionnant mais le son d'un
volcan en éruption à ce que ça fait du
bruit est ce que c'est aussi
impressionnant
oui alors ce volcan il fait une
irruption de type strombolien alors
c'est l'irruption qu'ils restent calmes
encore veut dire presque modeste et il
est temps de dire ça mais sur une
échelle de 0 à 8
023 projette donc des coûts d'eads avait
aidé ça a libéré que l'état s'apprête et
sans bien sûr beaucoup de bruit des gros
dégâts matériels
7000 personnes évacuées mais
heureusement zéro mort zéro blessé
patrick timsit principal quand même
étonnant qu'il n'ait pas de victimes
quand on voit de ces images-là
transmises par elles ne sont pas en
direct c'est un combo un
montage d'image 2d des coulées de lave
du volcan à las palmas ces derniers
jours des coulées de lave d'ong
rougeoyantes on est impressionné par
l'ampleur de s'écouler et on est étonné
effectivement vous disiez des milliers
d'habitants ont évacué des milliers
d'habitations en se vit sous ces coulées
de lave comment on a pu prévenir à temps
les habitants savent à quelle vitesse
une coulée de lave
il faut dire que mes collègues
sismologues
crise sismique une semaine avant déjà
avant le 19 septembre avec des séismes
qui était de plus en plus de plus en
plus important est de moins en
poursuivre et quelque part le magma
monte un peu comme une échographie un
petit peu et on voyait que l'éruption
était inévitable et les derniers dernier
séisme était à moi -
option à l'arrivée donc il y avait eu
une semaine déjà de préparatifs
judicieusement déjà les personnes qui
étaient à mobilité réduite avait déjà
été évacuée il ya quelques dizaines et
les autres personnes étaient était
prévenu d'avoir de quoi partir
rapidement un bagage minimum partir en
voiture rapidement aux moindres si
et ça a été fait et c'était une réussite
seulement alors malheureusement en
compte comme on compatit pour toutes ces
personnes qui ont tout perdu leur belle
maison et puis le leur culture leur
jardin mais faut se réjouir que tout le
monde soit sain et sauf vous parlez de
secousses sismiques qui ont était
antérieure à l'éruption et au réveil de
ce volcan c'est c'est précisément ce et
c'est ces mouvements sismiques ces
mouvements souterrains de notre planète
qui ont qui ont généré ce réveil du
volcan
alors non c'est pas les six francs
générée le réveil ce
qui se traduit par des fracturations du
volcan profondeur donc des cassures donc
des séismes alors s'ils avaient déjà vu
d une crise sismique en 2017 il ya
quatre ans mais les séismes étaient à
moins tranquille
et puis cette fois ci c'était moins 20
km - 10 km - km dont conti ont signalé
que le prêt est en train de monter alors
c'est lé séisme est encore modeste 1
magnitude entre entre 1 et 4 jusqu'à 4 8
le meurtrier qui pourront des dégâts
notamment en asie qui peuvent atteindre
7 8 ou 9 de magnitude a donc cédé 7 me
typique de l'atfd volcaniques qui sont
des témoins également mes collègues ont
enregistré une inflation du volcan a
gonflé à s'injecter donc quand on a
gonflé mandat volcan et qu'on ait des
microséismes ça veut dire qu'une
éruption peut arriver c'est pas sûr mais
que le magma est un traitement
qui décide mais il peut sortir et peut
faire une éruption c'est ce qui s'est
produit jacques marie bardintzeff c est
ce que c'est pas malgré tout une
surprise qu'ils se soient réveillés
maintenant en préparant cette émission
je disais que on attendait un réveil de
ce volcan sur las palmas plutôt dans une
vingtaine d'années
alors ça c'est
50 depuis le le sel est le seizième
juste récit si l'éruption s'est encore
entre une et deux par siècle en moyenne
donc la dernière avec la commande 50 ans
donc au contraire va dire que c'est un
peu
maintenant c'est une périodicité de on
va dire un siècle plus ou moins un
siècle en cas cela qui se passe rien un
siècle à deux éruptions donc on va dire
que le volcan et les petites heures meur
fin malheureusement pour les habitants
mais c'est signe que c'est les îles
canaries sont des épaules qu'annick et
c'est vrai pour toutes les îles de
l'archipel
est ce que on a une idée désormais au vu
des images qu'on a diffusé en direct et
de ce qui se passe depuis 30 jours de
d'estimer à peu près un moment où cette
cette fureur du volcan va se calmer où
va s'arrêter
ou de chercheur à être à bien un jour
mais comme je disais on à
l'aps de temps entre trois semaines et
trois mois donc là on en est un mois
donc il peut s'arrêter demain il peut
sauter dans un mois dans deux mois
malheureusement pour les habitants qui
t'attendent blessure à l'arrêt mais là
il ya un stock de magma train d'être en
train d'être libéré donc c'est des
séismes qui vont nous dire ce qui se
passe et comme depuis ce matin on a un
peu moins de sismicité donc qu'est ce
que ça veut dire faut bien sûr prendre
du recul à attendre un peu voir ce qui
se passe
est ce qu'on peut considérer que pour
l'instant les éruptions et donc dans une
durée normale même si on sent une
impatience à preuve en est les missions
qu'on consacre aujourd'hui en direct
c'est quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter
mais est-ce qu'on est dans une durée
normale d'éruption pour un volcan de ce
type oui
si on est dans les temps le timing
normale et malheureusement c'est plutôt
encore en moi
ouais le trémor comme on dit qui montre
l'activité du volcan
voilà on est au chevet du volcan les
volcanologues
des médecins je vais la passion des
sanctions et du volcan il ausculte pour
l'instant ils ont remarqué que les
coulées de la
surface qu'elles ont plutôt tendance à
stagner à d'ailleurs donc le volcan qui
a séché donc monté en activité sur
peut-être ce sera déjà un palier platini
sera rivée à son maximum peut-être
serait déjà
les signes celle à l'intensité la
vitesse où le volume des coulées de lave
qui est un signe qui pourrait indiquer
que l'activité du volcan est en train de
s'affaiblir et sinon si c'est pas les
coulées de lave à proprement parler
quels signes vont montrer en définitive
que ça y est on est sur une pente
descendante et et le volcan va se
rendormir un petit à petit
mais ce sera une belle à la sismicité
donc à suivre est également le humain
est un bon et un bon navigateur donc
c'est vrai que les observations verront
que la le panache de cendre au mans - o
pour l'instant les mandats quatre mille
lettres il peut baisser les coûts les
dollar avant seront moins vite elles
sont moins épaisses elle ce qu'on stagne
et donc ça peut s'endormir comme il
s'est réveillé un don est à la fois le
humain mais également et tous les
appareils de volcans est truffé
d'appareils deux
donc c'est vrai que l'inflation le
gonflement du volcan et la micro sim
indicateur de la santé du volcan
l'avait elle vient d'où exactement
est-ce que c'est dans la surface
extérieure du volcan qu'elle s'était
amassée ou bien elle vient de plus loin
et est ce que cette source de l'atari
sable et donc ça peut couler comme ça
indéfiniment tant que l'activité est
présente
enfin le mcba on dort on parle de magma
le mama secondaires moins 100 km alors
c'est beaucoup et pas beaucoup inséré
faut penser que le rayon terrestre c'est
plus de 6000 km donc c'est encore ce
gars
pour nous français c'est paris orléans 1
donc 100 km et il faut que ce magma
monte
poteau terrestre puis dans la croûte et
après ils ce stade dans une chambre
magmatique l'actuel mandat des six mais
pas moins 35 km dont il apparaît qu'avec
une fusion du mantois moins 35 km à la
nuit de la protée du manteau le manga se
forment et réalimenter le volcan donc
pour l'instant on a d'essayer pas moins
35 km d'allées l'isma moindre kilomètre
en corner mais très souvent deux états
ont la fusion du manteau à moins 35 km
montée du magma dans la coulisse tagab
10 km a pu remonter dernière fois dont 5
km alimentera s'y passe à -10 qui
alimente ce qui se passe en surface ça
va continuer et jours d'un salarié
comme un robinet qu'on ferme n'y aura
plus de magma qui va sortir le soir ils
sortent deux façons soit sous forme de
coulées daf qui se dégage
c'est aussi dans des projections papa
est fragmentée en bombe en bloc en
touche et ensemble ils sont reprises par
les vents qui recouvre une partie
importante au niveau superficie
jacques marie on est effectivement la
sueur a à rester un peu et à
s'appesantir sur sur le magma d'où vient
le magma sa quantité et comment
fonctionnent ces coulées de lave vous
évoquez ce que peut rejeter aussi dans
les airs et dans l'atmosphère les
volcans qu'est ce que rejette le volcan
de la palma en ce moment dans les airs
on voit ces espèces si julien qu'une
elle peut nous montrer les images en
direct
on voit de la fumée on voit des
explosions voilà on les voit ces
explosions noir est ce qu'il s'agit de
cendres et si on rentre véritablement
dans dans le détail jacques marie
bardintzeff qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
évacue le volcan en ce moment dans les
airs
oui bah c'est des roches l'on appelle du
visage au sens large ok ou d'été frites
qui est pulvérisé donc de magma les plus
de vergers en fragments lors les
fragments les plus grosses a fait ce
rappel des bombes volcaniques ont la
taille d'un ballon de rugby puisque est
plus fin qui fait moins de 2 mm jusqu'à
quelques microns sont décentes des
fragments infime mais qui sont dangereux
parce que s'ils sont inhalées ou avalé
par des êtres vivants que ce soit des
humains des animaux c'est très néfaste
et ses sandales sont trop chers qu'à
4000 mètres d'altitude puis reprise par
les vents dominants donc selon le sens
du vent l'aéroport de la palma était
parfois fermé parce que recouvert de
sang et puis parallèlement comme la voix
sur vos images il ya du gaz donc ce qui
est blanc l'art ce qu'on voit c'est de
la vengeance et la vapeur d'eau donc
c'est pas toxique mais c est chaud comme
ces boules en effet également il ya du
gaz qui a émis ces du gaz carbonique qui
est bien sûr qui est toxique y avait
également du dioxyde de soufre qui peut
également créer ce rappel des plus acide
donc c'est vrai que c'est eux très
agressif pour des êtres vivants animaux
enfin humains animaux végétaux
le danger justement de ces fumées et
leur toxicité
à la distance à laquelle sont maintenant
les habitants est ce qu'il ya un risque
encore aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est ces
fumées toxiques vont envahir l'espace et
stagner au dessus de l'île de la palma
et générer des incidents
respiratoire sur les gens qui vivent
encore sur place
bien sûr qu'à une zone d'interdiction
fait d'exclusion qui a été tracé par mes
collègues donc les gens qui sont autour
aprionis ne risque pas ils peuvent être
un sur incommodé de temps en temps ne se
risque pas pour leur fille faut savoir
que quatre mètres de haut c'est bien sûr
impressionnant mais ça reste encore
modeste parce qu'on est encore dans
l'année pas dans la stratosphère les
grandes évolutions majeures comme
l'éruption de pompéi en 79 après
jésus-christ la colonne démontrer à 32km
faut savoir la stratosphère quand ça
qu'un seul état qui tue donc en l'aller
les centres arrivent à la trace par la
stratosphère elles se répartissent
beaucoup plus donc ça ça te dirait des
éruptions pires cataclysmes and pour
l'instant l'éruption qu'on suit c'est
étonnant dire ça pour un vote annuel
reste quand même dans un modeste ou du
niveau 2 sur une échelle qui va de 0 à 8
donc voilà c'est un peu comme les autres
sont pressés pour ça reste localisée
d'une éruption finalement un pas si
importante que ça à une échelle qu'on a
à 2 sur une échelle qui peut monter
jusqu'à huit mais qu'est ce qui nous
empêche de penser que ça peut dégénérer
et finalement le volcan peut s'énerver
si je puis dire est rentré dans une
fureur encore plus importante et
finalement créé des dégâts beaucoup plus
importants
on peut rien exclure mais pour l'instant
l'éruption condamné en assises
correspond aux élections précédentes
le niveau 2 les six éruption historique
qu'on connaît a eu un niveau 2 pour
l'aca c'est un niveau 2 les le magma qui
est émis il est connu aussi ce qui se
passait semble bien bien compris bien
bien contraint donc bien sûr on peut
rien exclure il faut être très vigilant
mais pour l'instant le volcan a l'air
d'être bien sûr c'est important ce qui
fait mais ça reste dans ses cordes dans
son domaine d'activité on va dire dans
sa normalité on parlait de ces fumées
toxiques c'est vrai quand on voit ces
images on est impressionné par le volume
de ces fumées rejetées en permanence un
ça fait maintenant trente jours que le
volcan crache des fumées en plus de ces
coulées de lave ces fumées là elles ne
disparaissent pas elles envahissent
l'atmosphère les pays avoisinants même
s'ils sont de l'autre côté de la mer ils
vont toucher les côtes africaines
peut-être vont-ils vont elles mentent et
emportées par les vents vers vers
l'europe à ce qu'il ait un risque d'une
pollution de cette de ce volcan sur les
îles canaries jusque sur l'europe et
l'afrique
donc voilà ça c'est quand même très
limité l'éruption est un modeste
quelques kilomètres de hauteur s'est
pris par les vents donc que ça retourne
déjà sur las palmas au tour mais avant
que ça ici loin donc plus ça va plus et
diluée donc c'est vrai que c'est passé
ce genre d'éruption qui crée le plus de
soucis au niveau climatique avec des
options bien plus importante là par
exemple à une éruption en 1191 aux
philippines depuis la turbo qui a envoyé
une colonne de gaz et de cendres un
panache à 48 d'altitude effectivement ça
serait partie sur l'hémisphère nord on
ressent des modifications température
légère mais enregistre à l' on peut
enregistrer des retombées d'acidité dans
les glaces des pôles tout ça pour
l'instant l'éruption auquel on assiste
c'est beaucoup plus petit que c'est
beaucoup plus modeste donc ça ne met pas
en danger les autres continents je crois
avoir lu que par le passé les éruptions
précédente de ceux de ce volcan dont on
rappelle le nom le congrès vieira sur
l'île de la palma aux canaries n'avait
pas engendré ans dire de destruction
massive d'habitation la coulée s'était
fait un peu plus loin loin des routes et
des habitations nombreuses et des villes
à l'agglomération concentré cette fois
ci ça n'est pas le cas vous l'avez dit
plusieurs milliers d'habitations
détruites en celui des milliers de
personnes évacuées
certains s'interrogent est-ce qu'il
n'était pas possible et est-ce qu'il
n'est pas possible de détourner
le flot du magma et les coulées de lave
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de le faire ça
c'est quasiment impossible un gars su'l
ont fait des tentatives il ya eu lutte
et
d'un petit peu sur l'etna d'une fois en
islande il faut savoir qu'un flot de là
c'est quand même honteux de volume c'est
une grande puissance et d'état et roche
qui avancent donc c'est illusoire donc
lutter contre une coulé on peut gagner 5
ou 10 mètres mais quand c'est qui fait
plusieurs kilomètres et qui recouvre une
grande surface ne peut rien faire donc
c'est vrai que faut savoir que
volcaniques qui font des éruptions de
temps en temps et donc malheureusement
balles et les gens qui habitent ici et
sont exposés mais dans le monde il ya
total
des centaines de millions de personnes
plus ou moins exposé aux risques
volcaniques que tôt ou tard voilà donc
c'était chaud et le naturel il y en a
dans l'ensemble du globe et on peux pas
faut bien invité quelque part aussi donc
papa l'a créé toutes les régions à
risque parce qu'il ya eu tellement de
régions qui seraient voix
il sauve en
préparant cette émission je disais que
le volcan combrée vieira et n'était
qu'un des trois volcans présents sur
l'île rien ne dit que les deux autres ne
vont pas se réveiller ou ou finalement
ils sont vraiment définitivement dormi
en fait on regarde le long d'une
ligne ligne volcanique avec d'un
alignement de cratères en 1971 des eaux
et lila sont mieux de lille donc c'est
vrai que le long de cette fissure
oui alors ça peut être une autre
éruption qui peut prendre la suite dans
un mois
je vous dis c'est ce genre de d'éruption
c'est à une fréquence de un siècle plus
ou moins si elle est donc la victoire
dans ton 0 parfaite entre deux par
siècle donc c'est vrai qu'on peut rien
exclure mais c'est pas parce qu'il ya
une éruption ici qu'un apport soit une
après voilà c'est quand on sait qu'il ya
une fissure éruptive qui est bien repéré
par mes collègues géologue
à ceux qui nous rejoignent en ce moment
en direct sur lefigaro.fr et notre
chaîne figaro live sur youtube je suis
désolé pour les petits inconvénients
techniques qui font qu'il ya des
micro-coupures de son avec notre invité
est effectivement thomas carton sur le
chat figaro live youtube nous signale et
en précisant que c'est dommage parce que
c'est passionnant effectivement notre
invité nous donne un certain nombre
d'informations passionnantes sur ce
volcan en éruption sur l'île de la palma
dans les canaries un mois maintenant que
le volcan est réveillé et en éruption et
comme vous le voyez sur ces images
diffusées en direct rejette des fumées
toxiques de la lave et du magma s'écoule
depuis 30 jours des flandes de ce volcan
une partie de la population a évidemment
été évacués puisque plus de 2000 et 2000
habitations ont été détruites dans sur
l'île sur une partie de l'île ces images
que vous voyez ne sont pas en direct en
revanche ce sont des images qui ont été
tournées il y a quelques jours de
l'avancée de la lave sur les routes on
le voit sur les infrastructures de l'île
jacques-marie barzeh fonsny a répondu
tout à l'heure mais on le j'aimerais
vous poser la question en voyant ces
images très impressionnantes à quelle
vitesse avant si une coulée de lave
'bonne nouvelle' a peu avancé quelques
dizaines de mètres quelques centaines de
mètres à l'heure donc changer assez
moins vite que quelqu'un qui marche donc
ça veut dire que je fais que des coulées
de lave ne font pas de victimes sauf
malchance au soffin prudence et c'est ce
qui s'est passé donc les gens ont pu
partir un temps et les coulées d'avancé
sur inexorablement mais c'est vitesse
qui reste on va dire inférieure à
quelqu'un qu'il marche alors localement
bien sûr on peut avoir
quelques centaines de mètres à grande
vitesse mais après l'éclatante diminue
cela s'arrête même si les images sont
splendides et que des coulées de lave
nous rappellent certainement pour
certains de du bonbon qui coule c'est
absolument tentant d'aller y mettre le
doigt on va dire évidemment on ne
s'approche pas d'une coulée de lave et
justement à à quelle distance on doit se
positionner pour observer en toute
sécurité à une coulée de lave a
levé la semil paix il faut savoir que
quand on est prof faculté de l'âme c'est
intenable donc c'est vrai que quand
quelques mètres où peut même prélever là
là là bien évidemment c'est interdit
comme le volcan le
statut change d'humeur
de jour en jour les autorités ont
décrété un périmètre de sécurité ou des
interdit d'aller sauf ponctuellement
pour des spéciaux les scientifiques puis
si deschamps avait récupéré des des
affaires dans leur maison en raison des
inondations ponctuelles mais sinon c'est
une zone d'exclusion
[Musique]
la lave est passé la vie ne reprendra
pas ses droits ou bien au contraire la
lave est riche en nutriments ou en tout
cas en matière qui peut permettre à la
végétation de revenir dans un certain
nombre d'années on imagine
bien comprendre ans alors ça prend du
temps parce que bien sûr s'est mis tout
et minéralisée mais on va dire que est
déficient dans la lave donc le vendre à
des graines ces graines germées cas pas
il y aura des insectes y aura des petits
rongeurs de m'en venir petit à petit ça
va se refermer sur faudra un certain
temps avant qu'on retrouve vraiment à la
luxuriance précédente mais sur une île
comme ça qui est temps qu'un peu près
des tropiques qui est où il fait très
chaud il faillit le feuillage des leds
l'humidité donc pour la végétation c'est
très utile donc c'est vrai que c'est la
frontière des oligo-éléments elles sont
fertiles donc
il va retrouver à terme sas à côté on va
donc là pouvoir reprendre ses droits
dans dans quelques années on l'a vu il
ya quelques jours on a vu que les
coulées de lave son temps ce sont en
partie
déversées dans la mer et elles se sont
solidifier au contact de l'eau froide et
ça a modifié une partie de l'aspect de
la côte est ce que ligne pourrait se
trouver agrandi par les coulées de lave
et donc avoir sont sont sa surface sa
superficie modifié dans les atlas
oui absolument faut savoir que lille
s'est formée grâce au volcan s'éteint
venant des données par cas des sous
marins qui s'est agrandie qui a émergé
et qui petit à petit d'éruption
d'éruption apprentis donc soit il
grandit grandit en hauteur sont à placer
donc ces graisses mer eh bien elle
augmente la surface de 10 leurs
consoeurs d'être conscient qu'il était à
avancer sur la mer sera en partie
détruits par les vagues à la mer aux
cils et agressive et érode tout ça donc
ça peu un combat
mais un deal est le terreau est et la
mer mais lille va sortir un petit peu
grandi donc c'est vrai que la veut dire
la cartographie du tour de lit peut être
un peu modifié et quelque part c'est
aussi une bonne chose que les il se
forme comme ça parce qu'il ya plein dit
volcaniques dans le monde qui ont été
formés grâce au volcan qui sont habitées
on peut penser à la ligue de la réunion
on peut penser au pacifique tahiti on
peut penser aux antilles donc elles
nombreuses îles volcaniques où il fait
bon vivre seulement grâce aux volcans
quand même est ce qu a contrario l'île
de la palma pourrait disparaître du fait
de ses activités volcaniques
va disparaître d'un seul coup no 1 ce
qui peut se passer quand un volcan
fonctionne longtemps il se vidange et
donc peut s'effondrer donc c'est vrai
qu'un seul quand il peut gagner du
positif il peut aussi faire du négatif
en altitude mais pas que lille va
disparaître comme la 30e' de l'atlantide
a donc a priori non c'est lille est
stable elle est trouvée depuis l'on me
dise depuis longtemps ll ya des
modifications qui restent locales et
c'est vrai que ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est
impressionnant 50 ans ce sera assimilée
au paysage
jacques marie bardintzeff c'est vrai
qu'on a toujours ses petites difficultés
techniques pour vous entendre tout à
fait parfaitement mais c'est pas grave
vous a quand même bien compris et bien
entendu on arrive donc au terme de ce
direct et je vous en remercie je vous
remercie d'avoir été disponible pour
nous livrer tous ses éclairages et ses
explications sur le volcan pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent juste en ce moment le
l'intitulé de notre direct aujourd'hui
c'était quand est ce qu'on va bientôt
voir ce volcan se calmer est ce que les
coulées de lave on s'arrêter
s'interrompre est ce que jacques marie
bardintzeff vous pouvez conclure en nous
disant voilà ce qu'on peut dire en
l'état actuel aujourd'hui sur
l'évolution de l'éruption de ce volcan
qui dure depuis un mois
l'éruption
les six éruption précédentes ont duré
entre trois semaines et trois mois donc
le volcan est dense est dans sa moyenne
il peut s'arrêter demain comme il peut
durer encore deux mois ou plus donc on
verra on se donne rendez-vous dans un
mois avoir deux mois pour savoir si ce
volcan s'est définitivement assagi voilà
merci encore pour vos éclairages jacques
marie bardintzeff on va re préciser que
vous êtes volcanologues et professeur à
l'université paris saclay dans l'essonne
vous est également l'auteur de l'ouvragé
dont les deux derniers on les voit à
l'image pour le premier volcanologues
édité chez l'harmattan un livre sorti en
2017 et puis 7 cette dernière édition
volcanologie c'est la sixième édition
parue chez chez dunod dunod et
sorti en 2021 vous avez également un
blog je crois jacques marie bardintzeff
qu'on peut consulter sur internet vous
pouvez en rappeler le l'intitulé de ce
blog
oui s'appelle volcan magna donc je lui
raconte un peu les actus et des
scientifiques bien sûr je passe à las
palmas je parle également de ce qui
s'est passé en dix ans de cet été
actuellement je raconte un petit peu des
news ce scientifique les conférences en
cours voilà j'ai eu un coup de coeur de
temps en temps aussi
merci encore jardin zen pour pour vos
éclairages et d'avoir été en direct ce
matin sur figaro live et notre chaîne
youtube merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
également et d'avoir un peu compris
peut-être un peu mieux aujourd'hui en
quoi consiste l'activité volcanique
l'activité d'un volcan qui ne donne pas
de signe d'apaisement et c'est le cas en
ce moment avec ce volcan sur l'île de la
palma aux canaries dont on peut voir
pour se quitter les images diffusées en
direct elles sont capturés en direct en
ce moment voilà cette activité à ses
flamboyantes si je puis dire de ce
volcan entre les fumées toxiques et les
projections de de magma et de les
coulées de lave et puis ces projections
de de cendres et de pierres dans
l'atmosphère merci encore jacques marie
bardintzeff à très vite sur figaro live
au revoir au revoir